we can't even trust them on obviously
forget their reporting on coronavirus
they've been wrong from the very
beginning but now even when they talk
about their own personal experience with
coronavirus we saw this with NBC news a
reporter describing his personal
experience even that we can't trust NBC
News just when you think they can't lose
any more credibility just when you think
they're they're down to zero credibility
they somehow they they go into the red
they go into the negative on the
credibility column an NBC News reporter
these the science contributor and
biologist Joseph fair went on TV to
describe his personal experience with
coronavirus said it was the worst he
ever felt listen to his harrowing tales
of the virus doctor fair let me start
with you because I would like you to
share a little bit about your recovery
from Cova 19 what should Americans take
away from your experience well first of
all you know I did not have any
underlying conditions and you know I'm
not like a triathlete or anything like
that but I was generally very healthy
could run exercise probably four or five
times a week that being said I did not
expect whether if I got Kove in nineteen
that I would get that ill because I
don't have any of those underlying
conditions I'm 42 years old so you
wouldn't think clinically that I would
be one of those people that would get so
very ill I can say that that's seven to
eight days prior to me hospitalizing
myself when I was doing the seven the
self treatment that was the worst I've
ever felt I probably spent 23 out of 24
hours in bed and then obviously I
developed the secondary pneumonia at the
end and so the the struggle in breathing
and everything else so I was shocked at
how severe my illness got you know
without having those underlying
conditions that we've discussed so many
times I'm pretty shocked - I'm pretty
shocked to hear that 23 out of 24 hours
in bed that's that's not what seems to
be shown from the data what's what's
going on around the world certainly
around the country certainly for younger
men gosh that's really scary to me and
the doctor here there are they
scientific contributor the violinist has
some advice encouragement you young
you better take this virus seriously so
what I would take from that is you know
everyone that's younger everyone that is
going out without masks now and being
very cavalier with that and ignoring
this kind of ongoing pandemic and you
know we use the analogy and the band
played on with HIV and it's response
from the early days that's really the
analogy we should be using with
coronavirus right now to a much greater
extent and so those people that are
young and think they're invincible or
people that just don't think it's going
to affect them that greatly even if they
do get it I can say that my own
experience was the complete opposite to
that it really you know I can't say that
I had a brush with death but I was
enough to put me in the ICU for four
days and in the hospital for six days
can't say it's a brush with death but
it's pretty close huh
ICU for four days sleeping 23 out of 24
hours I mean I know that that the data
you know have contradicted all the scare
mongering from the mainstream media and
I know that all the experts and the
media the politicians have gotten
everything wrong but surely surely you
can't dispute this man's personal
harrowing experience it's scary right
it's crazy right well the craziest part
is he never had coronavirus that guy
tested negative for corona virus and
that guy tested negative for the
antibodies for corona virus he never had
it it's just completely 100% fake news
that video that testimony scandalized
even me and I have no respect for the
media and I don't believe a word that
they say the mainstream media the
networks and the New York Times and the
legacy newspapers I don't believe a word
they say and even I was shocked with how
brazenly dishonest that report was he
didn't have it he had something bad I
guess it sounds pretty bad but it wasn't
the virus and this is what we are basing
our public policy on this is what we're
basing the lockdown on this is how the
media work you because anybody listening
to that I don't care you the most
hardened skeptic of the lockdowns you
are as conservatives they get you here
that you say gosh I don't want that
virus
but it's fake news
[Music]
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description